hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to five nights at candy's
now I'm gonna try to finish this up
really soon but there is an Easter Egg
that someone told me about that I need
to find out about it's very personal to
me and me alone although I don't know
exactly if it was so what I'm gonna do
shallow you have two new messages
hey how's it going oh sorry I have a
latte here anyway I I have one last
thing to tell you all right you've
probably noticed that there is an extra
door in the second party room which is
on camera 9 and I think it's it's not on
the map that's because it's it's really
nothing special it's like a storage room
we don't go in there much like I haven't
even been in there myself you know I
just wanted to inform you that you don't
need to worry about it and that it's not
a mistake that it's not on the map or
anything like that anyway you've done a
great job so far I'll talk to you next
week good night
we fail our government immeuble my
pleasure
okay so apparently that did an easter
egg my face came up screens in house the
key why would they tell me about
something right as they activate it know
what that is that is Oh God
why would they do that oh that's so
creepy and weird oh that's good though
because it adds a little element of the
unknown or frankly I don't want to lose
these into it an explosion of poop oh
okay all right then well it seems to be
rather you know chill for like five
unless they have another surprise oh oh
let's say I have another surprise up
their sleeve for me I'm sure they don't
I'm sure nothing says the guys sipping a
latte and enjoying his life outside of
this hellhole of the restaurant okay oh
gosh okay all right it's like really
quiet by the way imagine it really quiet
I feel really really quiet like really
quiet Oh God
oh [ __ ] you uh-huh I got it let's cool
cool where's Momo hey mama hey mama mama
Oh God
hey [ __ ] you who is that
oh it's monkey boo Jojo okay okay
oh there's Momo
okay so Mama's coming up any check it
out
Oh daddy my laptop oh okay there is yeah
what do you know
if predicting the future eh oh hey
alrighty then you still there Momo how
would I know I don't know about them
okay hi
I saw you pop up their little Pangu
little penguin [ __ ] that's what I
thought he's being free I heard that hi
okay
ah uh I guess that's an exception
register oh man oh man that took me a
second
let's look me like a full second oh why
isn't he moved yet ah you [ __ ] Oh God
oh yeah hey thank you
oh god this is not okay oh it's not okay
having you daily in I'll move your blank
[ __ ]
oh well that was tough goddamn and here
I was complaining about how who seemed
to be lackadaisical and such
well anyway
let's continue on shall we alrighty then
so shut up okay so this was Easter Egg
just so it's clear that's me really I'm
in the game that's cool
someone told me that about that make up
comment so thank you guys for letting me
know about that so I'm pretty sure I
could probably get away with a lot by
just looking at the doors because I do
lose a lot of time by looking at the the
camera so what I need to do is I need to
make sure that I keep an eye on the
doors and then when the time comes watch
out for blank and Momoh so long as I
keep a bead on them it shouldn't be too
bad hmm okay this is getting a bit dicey
er but I'm still doing okay so mum was
gonna be creeping up on the left and its
second now and so long as I keep an eye
on these doors I should be a-ok maybe
everything that I do in life is a big ol
maybe ah see I don't know if there was
an auditory cue to Momo before because I
could have sworn that I heard something
but I wasn't even moving it
heimo see I hear something maybe I don't
need to look at all in the kid see there
was like a humming sound associate oh
yeah so if I just keep ear out for the
humming sound Inayat for everyone the
only other one that I need to worry
about is blank except for this
mysterious other door that they're
talking about I don't know the route
Pabu I'm like hi Momo what is that
why is a why is any of that that's a lot
of ding ding that's a lot of Bing bong
in that's a lot of musical boxing and I
don't like musical box because that
represents baby is that what we're
talking about in this other room that
you're talking about is that where the
baby is the baby did I don't want to
wake if I don't look at I don't look at
blank is he never gonna bother me thank
you
stop that stop that now you rude boy
double-teaming me huh
good thing I'm an expert at handling
that connection back in my day and old
five nights at freddys I used to get
double triple even quadruple teamed had
all times it was not fun to be honest it
was actually very unfun the opposite of
fun terrible that's the word terrible's
word oh I'm really time to concentrate
here so I'm not gonna be able to say a
lot cuz these nights are longer so they
do take a while
nights are long and full of tears I
never thought gamma throne would be to
true D'Mello Oh God
whoa Oh Oh God hi alright then good
handle that like a champ I'm wondering
about you just closed all my doors and
hope and pray that it's gonna last the
rest of the time
oh I heard haha
I have to laugh haha does anyone know
what I'm referring to
I have to laugh hahahaha but could you
imagine if we were gay
could you imagine I don't know the rest
of song our unicorn shine from heaven
blah blah blah blah bluh blah blah it's
one of my favorite songs from ninja sex
party if anyone out there haven't has
not ever seen the songs and music videos
of ninja sex party
please stop depriving your life right
now and go watch ninja sex party they're
amazing oh they're beyond amazing
they're everything that I wish I was
they're all a talent that I wish I had
such beautiful people and I'm glad to
call them my friends no but really
they're amazing go watch channels ninja
sex party if you haven't seen it
God what are you doing with your life
what am i doing in my life
alright let's not lose it right here at
the end
should I go full panic mode and close
all my shutters maybe I can probably
make it not that I'm scared or anything
Oh God all right that's going down
that's a alrighty then are we clear on
the left
oops
god damn it you know what I'm just gonna
ride this out cuz I'm pretty sure that
I'm gonna be okay
not 100% uh now got the sounds of a Momo
yeah it sure is
I think the other guy was coming soon
who's gone I'm not gonna be a baby about
hey how's about sailing me okay what
else you got for me what other names
loading record is this about room number
nine oh hi blank I can't do I can't move
on
hi Oh a mistake
Oh imma stay you're talking about me my
mistake
oh oh it's alright then just carry on
then a problem oh oh you're a problem
okay well you know it's your mistake
though so I think we gotta agree on
something here then
yeah good god I marry Schmidt I didn't
know that I was playing a female what is
whoa what is that oh no no no no wait a
minute here wait a minute
that is not an animatronic that was in
the game that frame there
am I an animatronic oh who knows ah
you're one of us now that's actually
kind of creepy considering that I might
be an animatronic
well okay then oh of course it's a
six-night so all right then so if you
want me to play the sixth night let me
know in the comments below there seems
to be some more mystery that's going on
here so let me know and I'll do as you
wish so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you
and the next video by three older horny
followkim you who already work for 30
seconds
Oh do it again